[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je pense à demain je dois vous
avouer que je suis un peu pour ne pas
dire beaucoup des primés changement
climatique disparition des espèces
pollution croissante problème de santé
majeur effondrement de la civilisation
le tableau n'est guère réjouissant sinon
angoissant et pendant ce temps là des
millions sont investis dans des start up
qui propose deux fantastiques
d'innovation qui ne servent à rien à
l'instar de cette machine à jus
connectés qui vous permet de précéder
poche contenant des morceaux de fruits
pour alizée des jus que vous auriez pu
sommes tout près c'est vous même à la
main quand je pense que cette innovation
repose sur 50 ans d'avancées
scientifiques dans de nombreux domaines
50 ans pour en arriver là
on n'arrête pas le progrès il y en a qui
aimeraient bien qu'il s'arrête le
progrès au vu de ses conséquences jugée
désastreuse et qui pensent que c'est la
nouvelle génération de savant fou
transhumanistes info j'ai originaire
east qui précipitera notre chute il y en
a d'autres qui pensent que c'est la
science et l'innovation qui nous
apporteront les réponses aux problèmes
que nous avons engendré
si ces deux visions s'affrontent
aujourd'hui c'est parce que la science
et la technique occupe une place
centrale dans notre société
elles sont en effet partout dans notre
quotidien penser la place de la science
dans notre société est une question
vraiment d'actualité
aujourd'hui on distingue la recherche
fondamentale et la recherche appliquée
la recherche fondamentale consiste à
explorer comprendre notre monde
le rendre intelligible parvenir à
l'expliquer c'est en effet là une des
motivations essentielles à la recherche
scientifique la recherche appliquée
consiste à transformer les résultats de
la recherche en produits et en services
aujourd'hui c'est une recherche qui est
massivement tournés vers une logique de
retour sur investissement d'un point de
vue économique dans un contexte où les
enjeux sociétaux vont croissant et sont
de plus en plus urgent à résoudre dans
un contexte où il est de plus en plus
difficile de faire l'autruche
pourquoi ne pas créer une troisième voie
de la recherche qui soit au service de
la résolution au service du bien commun
chez so science nous sommes convaincus
que les acteurs
qui porte la recherche des acteurs
publics comme les acteurs privés doivent
et peuvent jouer un rôle dans la
résolution de ces enjeux complexes et
mondiaux des acteurs nous le prouve tous
les jours des acteurs encore trop
méconnu aujourd'hui ces acteurs s'empare
des sciences pour agir pour définir et
développer des solutions ayant un impact
positif sur la société et sur
l'environnement
ces acteurs ce sont les entrepreneurs
sociaux scientifiques les entrepreneurs
sociaux scientifiques sont des acteurs à
la croisée de deux mondes celui de la
recherche scientifique et celui de
l'entrepreneuriat social
leur point commun utilisez la recherche
scientifique pour développer des
solutions qui soient à la fois
pertinente efficace et accessible chez
so science nous avons défini trois types
d'entrepreneurs sociaux scientifiques
les scientifiques qui deviennent
entrepreneurs les entrepreneurs sociaux
qui s'empare de la science et les
collaborations entre chercheurs et
entrepreneurs sociaux
cet homme derrière moi à droite
s'appelle bat kim nguyen il est
l'exemple typique du scientifique
devient entrepreneur social
kim est docteur en agronomie il a
réalisé sa thèse sur le thème de la
mortalité des abeilles et plus
spécifiquement sur l'identification des
causes de cette mortalité
il faut savoir que 90 % de ce que nous
mangeons aujourd'hui nous les permis
grâce au travail de pollinisation des
abeilles
une fois sa thèse imprimer ces résultats
publiés kim ne pouvait pas en rester au
simple constat il a voulu avoir un
impact fort sur le terrain et c'est
pourquoi il a créé l'entreprise sociale
bio diversity son idée ingénieuse
collaborer avec les abeilles pour former
un partenariat gagnant gagnant avec les
humains en effet les abeilles en
butinant et en rapportant le nectar à la
ruche permettent de récolter des données
sur leurs environnements tels que les
taux en pesticides et en métaux lourds
cet échantillonnage fournis par les
abeilles permet d'identifier les sources
de pollution qui influent sur notre
alimentation est donc sur notre santé
une fois ces sources de pollution
identifier l'équipe de biodiversity
conseil les différentes parties
prenantes présente sur les territoires
afin de les supprimer ce qui permettra
indirectement mais inéluctablement de
contribuer à préserver les abeilles
je vous présente maintenant gayatri data
exo de leur rencontre est né le projet
earth and a whole au rwanda ils sont la
preuve qu'une collaboration entre
entrepreneur social et scientifique peut
faire naître un projet à fort impact
gayatri s'est rendu au rwanda lors de
son cursus à standford dans le cadre
d'un cours dédiés à l'entrepreneuriat
social
l'objectif de ce cours était de
concevoir un produit ou un service qui
permettait d'améliorer l'habitat des
populations locales salihu que près de
deux millions de personnes chaque année
dans le monde meurent de la diarrhée
c'est la cause principale de mortalité
chez les enfants au rwanda une des
causes et l'absence de revêtement de sol
dans la plupart des maisons qui expose
ses habitants aux parasites présents
dans le sol gayatri a voulu répondre à
ce problème et a fondé l'entreprise
arsenal ball mais elle s'est vite
confronté à un problème pour développer
un revêtement de sol il lui faut des
connaissances en chimie des matériaux
c'est alors qu'entre en jeu récuse au
docteur en biochimie à stanford
il a développé un nouveau procédé en
chimie verte ya créé une huile végétale
qui permet de rendre les sols
imperméables
dans ce cas on voit que la recherche
scientifique a permis non seulement de
résoudre le problème mais elle a
également permis d'identifier des
matériaux locaux adéquats permettant
d'assurer une solution efficace
accessible financièrement mais aussi
tout en favorisant l'économie locale
voici maintenant marine couteau et
ladislas de tonnes d'ici les deux
fondateurs de l'eca une entreprise
sociale qui développe un robot éducatif
pour aider les enfants autistes à mieux
apprendre et à communiquer ils sont ils
incarnent l'entrepreneur social qui
s'investit dans la recherche
scientifique pour développer leurs
solutions
en effet ces deux anciens ingénieurs en
biotechnologie n'avait aucune
connaissance en robotique lorsqu'ils ont
lancé le projet en 2011
en mobilisant des experts ils ont pu
monter en compétences ce qui leur a
permis de développer le premier
prototype de motifs le robot éducatif
les entrepreneurs sociaux comme je viens
de vous en présenter des entrepreneurs
sociaux scientifiques comme marine comme
ladislas comme gayatri comme kim nous en
connaissons des centaines chez so
science par exemple qui développe des
drones pour aider à la reforestation qui
développe des emballages comestible pour
lutter contre la pollution plastique ou
encore des bacs
ries pour éclairer nos villes de façon
durable notre objectif chez so science
c'est de révéler ces nouveaux acteurs
ces pionniers au croisement de la
science et de l'impact social les
fédérer structure et ses dynamiques mais
aussi renforcer les synergies entre le
monde de la recherche et le monde dans
l'entrepreneuriat social afin
d'accélérer leur développement et de
diffuser les valeurs de la saion
sourgout alors oui je dois vous avouer
que parfois il m'arrive parfois de cd de
céder à ce sentiment d'impuissance et de
désarroi face à l'avenir qui se prépare
mais ce sont des acteurs comme les
entrepreneurs sociaux scientifiques qui
peuvent nous redonner force et
détermination face aux défis à relever
aucun d'entre eux n'a l'ambition de
sauver le monde mais chacun d'entre eux
contribuer à le rendre meilleur
il nous rappelle que chacun d'entre nous
peut assurer sa petite part de bien là
où ils se trouvent
il nous rappelle également que la
science loin d'être la solution à tous
les problèmes permet également de
contribuer à un monde meilleur
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]